hello everyone and welcome to the most
important tournament there ever was and
will be i'm of course talking about the
defeated candidates tournament it is a
tournament where the player who wins
will challenge their world champion
magnus carlson for the title or if
magnus for some reason decides not to
play then the first two uh
top contenders will battle it out for
the title of world chess champion of
world chess classical champion so it's
still um undecided because magnus still
did not
give sort of a green light if he will
defend his title or not he said that he
wants to face a real challenge or a true
challenger
and he said that he will be maybe
interested in playing alireza but
again everyone is saying that there is
just no way that he will
not play
regardless of who wins the candidates
tournament now as this is the first game
that we're showing from the candidates
and it's a beautiful one it lasted some
three and a half hours maybe a little
bit more than that and uh a most
unexpected um
uh result uh and maybe not the result
but uh
just the start of the tournament this is
round one usually in the candidates
you'll have a you know pretty calm round
one uh not much will happen but this
game is just
impossible to calculate it is just
really really awesome now like i said
this is uh the the first game that we'll
be showing a little bit about the
candidates tournament as usual it is a
double round robin so everyone plays
against everyone uh with both colors so
now ding has the white piece against
nipple and
in the second half of the tournament
nipple will have the white pieces
against the ding so
luck will not have all that much to do
with
uh who actually wins and it would be
silly if that was the case in the
candidates tournament now now like i
said usually only who wins the actual
candidates tournament matters because
that is the person who gets to challenge
the world champion but here as magnus
still did not decide if he will play uh
the first two places uh
uh are what players will be going for
definitely now of course there's the
money uh first place is 48 000 euros
which is uh of course a lot of money but
um none of these players really need the
money of course it is all about becoming
world champion or or at least just
challenging him uh so it will uh
it is uh being played in uh palace de
santana i already mentioned it is being
played in madrid in the previous video i
accidentally said barcelona i have no
idea why i did that but no it is in
madrid so if you are there maybe you can
uh check it out it will be played from
june 17th to july 4th and if it will be
a tie then we will have tie breaks
on
july 5th uh so that's pretty much it if
any of you guys are interested in any
more info on the tournament you can you
know just check it out online or maybe
just ask in the comments and i will
mention it in the next video uh
regarding the time control it is pretty
standard uh so you cannot offer a draw
before the
before move 40 has been played so no
early draw offers of course uh you get
two hours for 40 moves then one hour for
the next 20 moves and then 15 minutes
for the rest of the game with a 30
second uh seconds increment only from
move 61. so that's uh uh regarding the
the rules now let's check out the game
as there is there is quite a lot to
enjoy it is ding with the white pieces
he is the second highest rated player in
the world uh i believe now that alireza
dropped out of the 2800 club he's the
only 2800 uh player uh
alongside magnus carlsen but i will
check i don't want to trick you so just
give me a second
uh let me just quickly check this um
yeah dingle exactly twenty eight hundred
point four uh and uh uh alireza dropped
to 27.93 so yeah just uh you know making
sure so let's check it out it's a it's a
beautiful game ding has the white pieces
and he opens with um
and he opens with uh pawn to c4 he goes
for the english opening uh we have e5 by
nipple uh g3 and of course c6 uh sorry
about that uh we have knight to f3
biting and now uh pawn to e4 just
challenging the knight so this is a very
standard this is played quite a lot so
nothing out of the ordinary here knight
to d4 we have d5 c counters and now
queen captures you might be interested
in playing c captures on d5 to you know
improve your presence in the center uh
but it will be very easy uh for white to
undermine the center with bishop to g2
and d3 and it's not
not recommended so queen captures on d5
we have knight back to c2 as the knight
here is being attacked um uh so we lose
the tempo but we will win a temple with
knight c3 as the queen will have to move
so knights to f6 we have knights to c3
attacking the queen queen to e5 and now
we have bishop to g2 uh knight to a6 by
nipple uh you could uh also maybe play
knight to d7 but knight to the a6 is the
uh computer stock recommendation so of
course that's why he plays it castles
and now bishop chapter e7
and here ding plays knight to e3 which
is a very interesting move uh that he
already played in one game but we're
going to get to that
the engine stop recommendation seems to
be d4 here but it all depends on what
engine you are using i'm using a pretty
standard engine and maybe i allow it to
analyze the position maybe up to depth
30 if it's a really complicated position
i will you know take meta for a walk and
allow it to crunch the numbers maybe to
depth 50. but the d4 seems to be the
idea here just um you know freeing up
everything for example captures alpha
song queen captures and the game
continues uh but this uh
pawn on e4 really is stifling white's
development so okay dingo's knight to e3
it is the move he uh enjoys playing
uh also um maybe uh
interesting is knight to e1 is what
anish geary played against pragananda
and the tata still masters this year
they that ended in a draw but okay
knight to e3 and now we have castles uh
by uh by nepo uh also uh maybe worth
mentioning is uh ponte h5 was also
played in the game anishigiri as this is
obviously a line that gear enjoys
playing that he plays against alexander
vishuk uh in defeat a candidates
tournament in 2020 that ended in a draw
but okay here they continued the game
that the ding already played
we have a3 now
and uh here we have rook to e8 we have
pawn to b4 now grabbing more space here
uh now black will be able to maybe
challenge with c5 but this is exactly
what was played in the game uh dingle
iron versus han smoke and iman in the
charity cup in the preliminaries uh
where niemann defeated the ding with
this uh c5 idea but nipple uh doesn't go
into that because obviously or most
likely ding found an improvement in that
nipple just plays knight to g4 and this
is a completely new move so already as
of move 12 we have a completely new game
which for a candidate's tournament is
simply outstanding and uh nepo just
being nepo he's going for you know full
barbarian mode uh he wants to check made
the ding it's move 12 but he is going
for checkmate and that's why we enjoy uh
watching nipple play so how can ding
react to this obviously by playing this
he also left the defense of the e4 pawn
so maybe the e4 pawn can be captured but
this is something that nipple prepared
at home so you have to be very very
careful about capturing this pawn but it
seems to be the strongest idea we just
captured the pawn and if queen h5 we
play knight captures on g4 now bishop
captures and you get this position where
uh nipple would be up in development uh
he would be down upon
and he would have a very unpleasant uh
pressure here for example on the e2 pawn
the bishop not where it should be uh
it's uh it's just a very very funny
position to play and you do not want to
play funny positions against nipple
that he prepared at home so okay after
this knight to g4 move we have bishop to
b2 uh it makes sense as the queen is on
e5 nipple plays queen to h5 and now pawn
to h4 we have to defend against
checkmate pawn to h4 uh and here we have
bishop to f6 uh also an idea that most
likely was was prepared at home uh
because for example if f5 that is the
the engine stop recommendation uh you
just go into a very first line knight
captures on g4 queen captures queen to
b3 check king to h8 and now pawn to d3
and now you uh
destroy this advancement that black made
in the center and of course if e3 which
is what you are most afraid of you will
play queen to f7 e captures an f2 with
check rook captures now knight to c7
defending the rook now bishop to f3 we
attack the queen and black's attack is
over you have to play sound like queen
g6 we trade queens and the game
continues so this is possible but uh it
doesn't really give you all that much so
never plays for the goes for the much
more complicated idea bishop to f6 now
we have queen to c2 being prepares to uh
bring the rooks into the game now the
rooks are connected uh knight captures
an e3 d captures on e3 and now bishop to
f5 you have to guard this pawn it's
attacked three times and it's uh
sufficient to defend it twice because
you do not want to capture and you know
allow the uh this pin to to even exist
so here knight to a4 uh and bishop
captures on b2 uh being once the trade
off this this powerful bishop on f6
captures we have knight captures on b2
and now knight to c7 now it's uh it's a
question whether nepo can or cannot uh
start pushing with the g5 uh but you
know if anyone has this position uh
figured out it is definitely him so uh
he knows that he has to wait knight to
c7 knight to c4 by the ink and now rook
to e6 the knight is now coming to d5 and
you're not going to be able to kick it
away from there the rook can always come
into the attack with rook to g6 rook to
h6 you can open up the position with g5
then play rook to h6 so it's a very very
complicated position and uh of course
dean has to throw it very carefully so
rook f to d1
now comes knight to d5 and the rook to
d4 now he wants to double up rooks and
the d file and indeed this is the way to
go now we have to consider g5 always and
it's very hard uh to imagine that nipple
actually has things prepared up to this
point and he did use time
so i don't think he he is within his
preparation but of course the
preparation is so vast that even if he
had this position of course he doesn't
remember it exactly but he knows uh the
the tactical ideas and what to look for
but it is worth exploring for example g5
we're gonna play bishop to f3 that's the
move that kind of saves ding
because now you're attacking the queen
and of course if captures then we play a
queen captures an f5 so let's say queen
g6 now we're gonna play g4 and now g
captures on h4 and it's still very very
hard for white to survive this king h2
he captures an f3 queen captures on f5
now we're gonna play f captures on e2
and okay we we can have a trade here
captures f captures and black is up to
pawns but you are going to win the e2
pawn and of course the game will be
better for black uh maybe even much
better for black it's hard to say if you
will be able to push this uh
all the way to a win in in a classical
game so instead never plays h6 he first
prepares g5 also gives his king a little
bit of breathing room
uh and now comes uh the move that
basically uh ruins the game for the it's
hard to say if if the move loses by
force but it's just impossible to find
the moves after you play this so uh what
the ding should have played is rook
eight to d1 that's the move that uh he
was planning to make but for some reason
he first decided to play queen to d to
to triple up on the d file and now the
problem is uh if nepo executes g5 now
this is uh possible rook captures on d5
and this is the move that exists and it
will not exist after queen to d2 because
this just saves you now the bishop is
hanging and of course if c captures on
d5 the other rook comes into the game
now we play g captures on h4 so the
queen defends the bishop but now comes
knight to d6 we pile up on the bishop
here and rook captures on d6 even this
can be played rook captures we're going
to play h captures on g3 but not just f
characters and g3 and you say okay uh
you've opened up my king a little bit
but my position is fine your attack is
over there is nothing happening here so
rook 8 to d1 definitely the way to go
after nip was h6 here but the dink
played queen to d2 and now without this
resource of rook captures on d5 uh
it's just hopeless uh so first rook
eight to e8 he wants to now defend the e
for pawn uh and uh he's gonna play g5
next that's that's the
that's the whole point and now uh ding
doesn't really have rook a to d1 and
it's pretty pointless to make such a
move but we could explore just what
happens the problem is after g5 there is
no rook captures on d5 the problem is
after rook captures on d5 now we're
going to play c characters and after
queen captures on d5 h captures on g4
now it's much much different than if the
rook was on d5
because after knight to d6 we just play
h captures on g3 and now how do you how
do you defend this if queen captures an
f5 queen to h2 with check king to f1 and
now g captures an f2 with threat and
checkmate but also the queen here is
attacking the knight here and the rook
also is attacking the knight on d6 so
you can't defend against everything even
if queen captures an f7 king to h8 that
there is no continuation here for ding
uh it's just a very very sad position
and now it doesn't matter if you play
queen captures on f2 then of course the
knight here hangs and if you try king
captures uh it's it's not much better we
just play rook g8 go after the bishop
here and once you defended this we're
gonna play queen h4 king to f1 and rook
captures on d6 again we're up too much
material and of course you are getting
checkmated there's no no defense against
this
so uh rook to d1
uh doesn't really do all that much for
ding and ding realized what he what he
did here by placing his queen on d2 he
went into a deep think and after a very
long consideration he played king to h2
which is kind of what you do when you
expect your opponent to lash out on the
king side you want to play rook to h1
bring the king back to g1 and then if he
opens up the position then maybe you can
use your rook on the h file as well and
the king will be much much safer uh so
nipple agrees with him he says well this
is quite the move uh so i'm going to
wait with this um g5 idea let's play
bishop to g4 first now we're gonna we're
now we're threatening the e2 pawn and
also you constantly have to uh worry
about bishop to f uh bishop to f3 and
there are many many tricks in this
position
but the ding just says knight to a5 he
says i'm going after the b7 pawn uh and
you you don't really have a a an attack
that will will work here uh and uh even
though g5 works here nipple doesn't play
it he goes rook to f6 first and it is
the safer choice because after g5 uh for
example rook to h1 the move that being
played g captures on h4 king to g1 and
h3 there's bishop to f1 and it seems
like uh ding survives the attack uh the
problem is nipple has this queen to f5
most likely the move that he missed uh
otherwise um he he would probably go for
this and now it's just um uh impossible
to to survive this there there are so
many threats uh and white is basically
without a move there is no good move
that you can make here uh rook to f6
will put more pressure on the f2 pawn
now you move the queen away from the h
file so h5 h4 is coming opening up the
position uh but of course uh you know
it's easy to say this after the game is
over and you you check with the engine
yeah in the actual game rook f6 is the
much better try uh as it already puts
pressure on f2 so queen to f5 will come
with um
with very dangerous pressure but also
you're just attacking the f2 pawn so of
course you have to defend this so king
the g1 biting this is in fact the
strongest move uh recommended by the
engine and now pawn to g5 finally
opening up the position and the question
is what to play here there is a there is
a move that uh
can maybe save ding but it's uh an
incredibly uh
hard move to make now it it all comes
down to this d5 square
if the knight on d5 you know
stands solid uh there's nothing you can
do but here the move that actually could
save the game for ding is pawn to b5 but
still it's gonna be
difficult to play this point is that
after the position opens up on the king
side we're going to play b captures on
c6 remove the defender of the d5 knight
and now after h captures on g3 of course
with the idea of just checkmating the
white king uh f captures and g3 we're
going to play queen e5 now we're going
to pin the rook as now if you move the
real queen captures on a1 will come with
check so knight to c4 kicking away the
black queen queen captures on g3 and now
queen e1 uh forces uh
uh forces a queen trade because the
knight is hanging the queen is hanging
and also you have to worry about the
ding just getting a pass pawn on b7 so
here we would see a trait for example
captures captures and b captures on c6
but now rook captures an e4 we're going
to grab this pawn let's say rook
captures bishop captures and you would
get this position where neville would be
up upon but the ding's spawn structure
is all messed up and well
if he plays this to perfection maybe he
can defend but it would be it would be
difficult
but the ding played knight captures on
b7 and now there is just no defending
the attack uh we have g uh after knight
captures on b7 we have uh g captures on
h4
and uh how do you how do you play this
uh there's just no good move here ding
brings the knight back knight to c5 and
now pawn to h3 and now ding is already
down below uh 10 minutes nepo has over
half an hour on the clock and there is
no good move if you move the bishop
doesn't really matter where you move the
bishop bishop to f1 just h2 check and if
king h1 rook captures on f2 you are
getting destroyed bishop to f3 will just
end the game here
uh and of course after h3 bishop to h1
is no better just bishop captures on e2
removing the defender of the f3 square
and now again uh h2 will just be
crushing everything is just uh happening
all at once there is no defending this
position so instead after this uh h3
move uh rook captures an a and e4 was
tried by ding but now uh just h captures
on g2 uh you could even play i'm just
going to show it because it's super fun
you could even allow dink to kind of
save his bishop with bishop captures an
e4 but now h2 check in h1 rook captures
on f2 again there is no uh no defending
this position you are uh now piling up
on e2 just a
complete mess of the position bishop f3
of course you cannot capture as the
queen would hang so
completely winning but a nipple goes for
the uh for the nicer idea he just plays
h captures on g2 now threatening queen
to h1 checkmate and uh it's not easy uh
he even gives up the rook on e8 with
check rook captures an e8 with check was
played king to g7 and now how do you
defend against checkmate
not really easy of course you cannot
grab the pawn uh there's the beautiful
uh forced mate with rook captures on f2
simply incredible king captures queen to
h2 with check king the f1 bishop h3 with
czech king the e1 and now queen to g1
will be checkmate so that doesn't work
ding tries f4 and now all nipple has to
do is figure out whether rook queen h1
followed by queen captures rook uh is
playable and if you know he can run into
some maybe knight to e6 check ideas it's
very unlikely but of course you have to
check this is the candidates tournament
so here queen to h1 check was played we
have king to f2 and now queen captures
on uh a1 basically the only winning move
but not very difficult to to spot it
king captures on g2 and now there are
many ways to win this position uh but
nipple finds the absolute quickest one
it is the first checkmate in nine and
that of course is bishop to h3 check
giving up the bishop and that's just it
it was in this position on move 32 that
dingle resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here so in 2022
with all of
the engine preparation that the the
players are equipped with i am saying
that a a 32 move game in the candidates
tournament uh is definitely considered a
miniature and uh this is just uh
incredibly incredible especially since
he found uh you know such a such a
deadly deadly uh line in a game that the
ding already played and he lost it to
han smoke and eamon uh
probably improved on it as well and and
nipple just played that
you know knight to g4 idea uh completely
in his style and completely obliterated
being just a
complete madness now you have to capture
the bishop here if you just move the
king let's taking h2 queen f1 and
there's no defense against uh checkmate
and of course if you capture the bishop
then the king hunt begins queen to h1
with check king g4 h5 with czech king g5
and now the beautiful queen h3
there is no defense here you just have
to give up pieces and once you give up
all of the pieces which which is pretty
silly but we have to try everything like
the queen b2 check f6 queen captures on
f6 these are all very silly moves but uh
just to show you how many moves you you
can survive until checkmate is given and
of course queen g4 let's say checkmate
but uh it's only uh you know
because you can give so many checks that
you can prolong the game but basically
bishop page 3 check his resigns and the
ding resigned here so incredible
incredible start to the candidates
tournament this is the first game that
finished the ding the highest rated
player in the candidates the only 2 800
player in the candidates uh loses the
former world champs championship
challenger yanni pomnishi who who you
know definitely starts the the defeating
candidates with a bang uh
crushing the the highest rated player in
in basically a miniature with the black
pieces so incredible stuff uh
i'm i'm very much looking forward to see
uh what else ian prepared as this was
incredible we we can just look at it i
mean it's so uh it's you know if if you
if you wanted to have like a move on on
your you know refrigerator or on your
wall or something you know knight to g4
just
so simple something everyone would play
in a bullet game nipple plays it in the
candidates tournament and it is enough
to take down dingler incredible
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i'm very much looking forward
to covering the other games uh so you
know unless it's a snoozefest hopefully
i will be able to cover all of them i
would like to thank uh sarkar david
kimura david chester nagarjuna ponogoti
and ks dillon for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament
until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day